yes finally a good game screw you
a Mass Effect Andromeda here we go here
we go everyone I hope you're ready what
the [ __ ] is this what does this game
seem like yeah they're good alive okay
let's play the actual game and see what
this game is all about I know where
you're thinking oh it's another boob
game no no it's not it's way more and if
you say that I find that statement to be
quite ignorant which is an anime
what is it [ __ ] I don't watch anime odd
disgusting this is why I voted Trump to
not see this gay [ __ ] what the what is
this they're putting flowers on the
grave are they gonna get naked soon do
you think yes yes yes you can't go from
funeral to ass what is happening what oh
god bless god bless God bless if this is
just intro can you even imagine the
gameplay my god
this reminds me of when I wrote when
Sasuke are fighting over there over the
waterfall I never understand how they
can make those sounds with how is that
racist for me to do owe me a dumb [ __ ]
what do they call a female Swan or so
call me that the writing it's so
beautiful it's unlike anything I've ever
read
I'm right at a fight and you you picked
a fight with the wrong youtuber
i'ma getcha and just imagine giant
medalists here that's why I'm gonna get
Jack she has a shotgun what is this what
how do we get from that to this what is
this gun
stop calling our [ __ ] look at her
[ __ ] battle sands I'm from the future
I'm about to [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
all right here we are finally again I
like how you see that no shame no shame
in this game whoever had made this game
it's shameless there's no shame no shame
whatsoever best game best game of the
year best game universe best game of all
time of all time every game oh my god
yeah you didn't spawn one how [ __ ]
many do you need to spawn what they [ __ ]
where do they all come from all right
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
fight back over there yeah why why shoot
the gun when you can [ __ ] spin and
[ __ ] hey your chin is out [ __ ] got him
whoa-oh they get naked
thinking naked I say shoot them bears
yeah yes keep shooting them oh this just
one left got him
shinobi transformation hockey game if
you give a [ __ ] oh wow what the [ __ ] she
gets giant dicks
that is the best thing I've ever seen
oh my god damn like right there what I
just I'm not leaving this computer you
don't understand you don't understand I
am going to plug this game into my
bloodstream I'm going to eat the 3d
printed food from that one there we go
Special Attack hell yeah look at that
damn [ __ ] kick-ass and it's got
nothing to do with my giant tits are you
always dancing or is it just like a
condition yeah she wouldn't oh I see it
now yes she has two guns in one head and
thank God I can't see my underwears
anymore or can I let me see if I can you
got to go close to a wall if you want to
see like clothes that you guys click
closer to wall change the camera and
then you know sad sad I'm sad holy [ __ ]
look at me this is an attack of the
Titans [ __ ] man look at it Sonic's here
nothing on this [ __ ] the music makes me
so [ __ ] Punk this is like having
cocaine I never had cocaine but I
imagine this is not as good I mean this
is better this is better don't do drugs
do enemy can you sand sill like just for
a second
Jesus Christ anyway moving on moving on
to the next battle I wonder if people
actually get into the story I'm really
curious because I played the game only
for the story nothing else all right so
now we get to play how about that after
knocking an enemy back okay why are they
so goddamn many of them whoa look at
that boy we're fighting on the water
this is just like Jesus Jesus the enemy
what is happening oh my god
what is happening hey what is happening
right now I click the button and then if
you button mash you will have a seizure
what is this oh I did it okay I did it
I'm naked now you know life's armor
makes you stronger everyone knows that
everyone knows that historians have done
it wrong all alone whoa I surf look at
this i surf I'm a [ __ ] surfer yeah
boy yeah boy what up died I'm a surfing
enemy fighting warrior princess can I
ride the banana can I ride the banana
answer me dammit I can't I can't right
perhaps later
yes I love Allah yes
when waiting so long till up a lot level
hundred I'm going for lever hundred I'm
not gonna stop playing until I'm level
hundred I'm courting YouTube I'm going
to play a MLG Sun run Kagura estable vs
here we go
finish that [ __ ]
you're thinking in math what happened to
the story of the game all I got so far
is naked girls fighting I'm sure there
is a story I'm sure of it
I'm 100% sure there's a story here
somewhere
Jesus Christ you can't be serious with
that [ __ ] you're wearing like a Nazi
outfit like what is that supposed to
resemble am I the only one that sees
this oh my god what the [ __ ]
illness Lee what the [ __ ] sure Wall
Street is gonna post about that
I'm sure justice to this game some say
that just makes the game better what do
I know you know believe it or not I
wasn't not stood before but after seeing
that I might reconsider that was a joke
what's a joke a joke about anime titties
I was an atom a titty joke I'm sorry I'm
okay
what the actual [ __ ] god bless god bless
america
I mean Japan goddamnit it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be a Japanese game with the the
slight rapey undertones what I say what
I say what did I say Asuka do I look
like a woman who's satisfied with her
own booze I'm gonna have to get back on
that one
something's happening something's
definitely happening it came from the
sacred queendom of boobs well now I know
where I want to go when I die that's
great how would I been looking into
different options hell was pretty high
on the list but I think we got a new
champion seeker Nazi sick you're not see
do you see it I see secret Nazi what the
[ __ ] you see it don't you it's in the
background in the pattern
okay submissions start aim for a wall
wall run and with a
oh whoa whoa games video games video
games are realistic look at that boy
look at this wolf trying to transform my
god I can I can't see 67 men escort an
amazing game like it's a lot of media
hate because our mainstream professional
critics are more worried about promoting
their social justice warrior agenda than
actually reviewing gameplay I rest my
case I've discussed it there is no god
this game deserves its own rating okay
this is the rating system and does not
go high enough Danny what are you what
are you doing well I hope you enjoyed
this video if you didn't be sure to
leave a like and a comment and subscribe
and if you did